braver le nouveau film de Disney et
Pixar présente des histoires courageuses place
tout le monde tant qu'ils sont une famille
parfaite royaume parfait vie parfaite non laissez-moi
vous dire à quoi ressemblent vraiment les choses
ici c'est moi Merida maman essaie d'
apprivoiser ma nature plus pour ici mais j'aime
c'est samedi quand tes parents sont
le roi et la reine pas d'armes sur la
table la vie de château peut être restrictive
napster j'ai besoin de vivre ma propre vie
suivre mon propre chemin j'ai souhaité que les
choses changent et c'est le problème semble
se déchaîner un très petit ancien
malédiction, je ferai n'importe quoi pour arranger les
choses et sauver le royaume, il
suffit d'être courageux